We can also shift parabolas, or move them around on the coordinate plane. Let's
take a look at our original equation, y equals x squared. If we add 1 to the
equation, we can see that the entire graph shifts up 1 unit. Notice before that
the vertex was at 0,0. And now, our vertex is at 0, 1. By adding one right here
to the end of our equation, we really increase the y values from before by 1.
This is why the entire graph, the orange graph, shifts one unit up. So a point
that was at negative 1, 1 is now at negative 1, 2. And a point that say was at
two comma four is now at two comma five. Notice how the y value increased by
one. We can also make this graph go up by two units, three units, four units,
or even eight units. So, we can see that adding a constant term to the end of
our parabola, will shift it up. So, if we subtract a number, it will shift it
down. The parabola, y equals x squared minus 3, is our original parabola, only
it's been shifted down three units. And again, notice that the orange parabola
had a vertex of 0, 0. And this new parabola has a vertex of 0, negative 3. We
could even change this to be a negative 5, so that way the orange parabola
would shift down 5 units. And again, notice that the vertex of this last
parabola is 0, negative 5. We can see that the y coordinate of the vertex comes
from here, this negative 5 is right here on our vertex. The x coordinate of our
vertex is 0. And it turns out it comes from solving this binomial or setting
this binomial equal to 0. X minus 0 is still x, so we know that this term is
really still x squared. And if I graph this equation, I can see that there
exactly the same. I'm just writing this in a different form. So, now we can
quickly see where this vertex comes from in our equation. The 0 is here, and
the negative 5 is here. Now, we've seen shifting the parabola up and down.
Well, we can also see a parabola shifted left and right. So, we know by adding
3 on the end, we could shift the parabola up 3 units. To shift the graph left
or right, we're going to change this binomial. If I subtract 1 from x, it
really moves the graph one unit to the right. Now the vertex is here. Notice
that the sign of the x coordinate of the vertex is opposite from the one in
here. For a y equals parabola, we can set this binomial equal to 0 to find the
x coordinate of the vertex. So in this case, x would equal one. The y
coordinate of the vertex is simply found by the number that's added or
subtracted at the end of the equation.